there you are in 1987 exchange student
in the Soviet Union what was that world
world like well that was absolutely
fascinating in that period because it's
the period
um that's just around the time of the
peak of perestroika mikhil Gorbachev's
uh role as president
um while he wasn't quite present at that
point it's all Secretary General of the
Communist part of the Soviet Union
trying to transform the whole place
so I arrived there in September of 1987
just as Gorbachev and Reagan sign the
INF treaty was just within you know kind
of weeks of them about to sign that
which really ends that whole period that
had shaped my entire teenage years of
the under the euromissile crisis by
finally having agreement on you know
basically the rejection and constraints
on intermediate nuclear forces
and also at this point Gorbachev is
opening the Soviet Union up
so we got all kinds of opportunities to
travel in ways that we wouldn't have
done before
um not just you know in Moscow which is
why I was studying at the transits
Institute but to the Caucasus to Central
Asia I went all the way to uh habarovsk
in the the Russian Far East all the way
around you know kind of Moscow and there
was at this point it was also the
cressian yerus which has become very
important now this is the anniversary
the thousandth anniversary of the
christianization of
um of Russia which of course has become
a massive Obsession of Vladimir Putin's
but you know 988 because I was there 87
to 88 and at this point the Russian
Orthodox Church is undergoing a Revival
from being repressed during the Soviet
period you suddenly had the church
stepping out as a non-governmental
organization and engaging in discussions
with people about the future of religion
so that was you know something that I
wasn't expecting to to witness
also I mean being in Moscow this is the
cultural capital of a vast Empire at
this point I'd never lived in a major
city before it's the first big city I
lived in I'd never been to the Opera you
know I that the first time I got an
opera it's at the bolshei you know I'd
never seen a ballet I mean I was not
exactly steeped in high classical
culture only kind of growing up in a in
a mining region you know there's very
limited opportunities for this kind of
thing I've been in an abuse Orchestra
and a used choir my parents signed me up
property everything you know they
possibly could education wise but it
wasn't exactly any exposure to this so
you know I was kind of astounded by the
sort of wealth of the cultural
experience that one could have in Moscow
but the main thing was I was really
struck by how the Soviet Union was on
its last legs
because this was Moscow you know I got
this image about what it would look like
I was quite to be honest terrified at
first about what I would see there if
it's a big nuclear superpower and as
soon as I got there it was just this
like as if a huge weight that I'd been
carrying around for years and my teenage
years just disappeared because it's just
ordinary people in ordinary players not
doing great this is the period
of you know what they call deficit you
know so the period of deficits but
there's no food in the shops there was
you know very little in terms of
Commodities because the
um supply and demand parts of the
economic equation were out of work
because it's a total Central planning
you know you'd go into you know a shop
that was supposed to sell boots and
there'd be just one pair of boots all in
the same size in the same color I
actually locked out because once I was
in this um Hungarian boot shop that was
right next to where my hall of residence
was and I was looking for new pair of
boots and every single pair of boots in
the shop were my size and they're all
women's boots they're not men's boots at
all you know because if it's been a
nervous supply of boots and that size
production but you could really kind of
see here that there was something wrong
and you know in the north of England
everything was closed down the shops
were shuttered because there was no
demand because bedwoody lost their jobs
it was massive employment you know when
I went off to University in 1984 90
youth unemployment in the UK meaning
that when kids left school they didn't
have something else to go on to unless
they got to University or vocational
training or an apprenticeship and most
people were still looking you know kind
of months out of leaving school and so
shops were closing because people didn't
have any money you know I had 50 male
unemployment in some of the towns as the
steel Works closed down and the the
wagon works for the railways for example
in my area but in Moscow people in
theory did have money but there was just
there was nothing to buy also the place
was falling apart literally I saw
massive sinkholes open up in the street
balconies fall off buildings you know
one accident after another
and then there was you know this real
kind of sense even though the vibrancy
and excitement and hope of the Gorbachev
period a real sense of the the Soviet
Union had lost its way and of course it
was only a year or so after I left from
that Exchange program and I'd already
started with my degree program in Soviet
studies at talford that the Soviet Union
basically unraveled and it really did
unravel it wasn't like it collapsed it
was basically that there were so many
debates that garbage offered sparked off
about how to reform the country how to
put it on a different path that you know
no one was in agreement and it was
basically all these fights and uh deep
debates and disputes among the elites of
the center as well as you know basically
a loss of faith in the system in the
periphery and among the general
population that in fact pulled it apart
and of course in 1991
you get some
Boris Yeltsin as the head of the Russian
Federation then a constituent part of
the Soviet Union together with the
presidents of Ukraine and Belarus all of
these being individual
parts of the Soviet Union getting
together and agreeing of essentially
ending it and gorbachevino so basically
I'm there at the the peak of this whole
kind of period of experimentation and
thinking about the future and within a
couple of years it's all kind of gone
and it's on a different track entirely